you very much for being with us I have
to say I'm quite excited about having
you both on the program together
um thank you for coming in thank you for
having us no good to see you
um so you've got a new book out you say
that politics is broken why
I think the big breaker of it has been
some of the issues you've just been
discussing Andy there I think populism
polarization and the fact that we're now
thanks to brexit and Boris Johnson in a
post-truth world similar to Trump
Trump's America and added to which I I
think that the a lot of people's
greatest generation are just sort of
looking at politics and thinking I think
they really really care about the world
really care about trying to make change
in the world but they're looking at
politics and how they see it done and
thinking this just doesn't has very
little to do with me yeah do you think
that's right then I mean I do yeah
increasingly so especially at the moment
the the Tories feel so far removed from
like most people I know and lots of
people of My Generation
Um and then also I think like culturally
they just feel really far removed from
us but I think I mean we've been talking
about this for such a long time actually
because since I started doing
activism I guess
um I I've realized how many young people
and this is when I was actually young I
feel like I I can't how old are you now
I just turned 29. that's definitely
still young I know my book that's well
that anything under 30 yeah but then
young people are like so much more
impressive you know like late teens
early people in their early 20s at the
moment are just doing such unbelievable
things but I remember thinking that when
I started doing all of that I was like
well there are all of these young people
who are unbelievably impressive and
inspiring but wouldn't consider a career
in politics and that's really depressing
it is quite depressing isn't it don't
you think do you think that actually
politics is turning off and I'm not even
making this party political but just
generally just turning off young people
from politics from running to bmps well
I think there's lots of I actually think
that the way that the media covers
Politics as well is a problem I think
people look at it and then social media
as well you know women young women and
women of color in particular the abuse
that they see other women getting it
puts them off but Grace is right I mean
you know I was really pleased to hear I
saw you to you Jonathan Reynolds I
really hope labor are going to fight to
lower the voting age I think that's
really important I I see the reason I've
written the book the title but what can
I do the title comes from the fact that
that's what young people say to me the
whole time but what can we do because
this isn't this isn't the politics that
we sort of feel we need and again I
thought Andy was interesting there that
you know the change that the politics
has it's got to be much more than a
change of government we've got to change
the way that we do politics and we've
got to understand young people have got
so much energy they have got so much not
all of them I remember I say in the book
that Grayson when Grace was like in her
teens and I said look we should lower
the voting age and I remember Grace
saying dad you've met some of my friends
they know nothing about me and I will
say yeah but 40s 50s 60s 70 year olds we
need we need we just need massive
political education in this country you
know what was the most Google thing the
day after the referendum what is the EU
I mean that's terrifying so I think that
Grace's generation is the answer to it
to a lot of these problems and and uh
you know we've got to have such big
change and it's but I think to in order
to get a lot of those people to want to
go into politics politics has to change
and the way that we treat politicians
has to change and I think that that you
know I think about this a lot I mean
less and less so but I used to get told
a lot that I should go into politics I
think now my my comedy is quite like the
opposite of what politicians are allowed
so there'll be a few things that are
quite problematic now yeah but I used to
get that a lot and it I know I never
ever ever was attracted to it because of
the abuse that you get and I I saw that
firsthand like my entire childhood and
then also the way that a lot of the time
you aren't actually allowed to say what
you think and how you feel and you have
to sort of you know you're really scared
of what other people and like what your
party might say to you and then the
abuse that women get online women of
color I mean it's just horrific like why
would you want to do that well because
you can change the world yeah but you
can change the world in other ways you
can I think that's the thing that people
see now now is that actually sometimes
you can have more power shouting from
the outside which maybe you know well
look at you look at you having a
Resurgence in your career now no you're
shouting from the outside yeah shouting
from the outside he's always been
shouting wherever he is however the
thing is for example about Gretch
tunberg
um Gretch tunberg is a great example of
somebody who an individual who just
started a protest and has made a
difference and it's true she's made a
difference but ultimately if you're
really really really going to make
change you've got to get in and Lead
governments that is where the big change
is do you think kissed armor is ready to
make big changes because in the
interview with John from Reynolds I
guess what I was trying to say is look
there's a lot of rhetoric right now
coming out of the labor party saying we
can be on Clause 4 on steroids they're
referencing 1945. where's the evidence
of a radical political policy I thought
I was really I watched your interview in
the green room and I thought it was a
really interesting interview because I
could see where you were coming from and
I could also see where he was coming
from what I really like about what care
has done is he's so methodical people
say he's dull and he's boring he's is
methodical and I think we need a bit of
that so he's gone stage one
decontaminate labor brand post the
Corbin period stage two show that the
Tories are absolutely useless and unfit
to govern stage three here's the big
positive agenda and I think what's going
to happen with these missions that
they've got and now this rhetoric as you
say is they're they're Now setting
themselves that Target for those big
policy ideas to come they've now got to
happen and I kind of agree with both you
and Jonathan I think there is a lot
there that they're they're projecting
but actually for the public there's very
little sense of how that's going to
change affect and change their lives and
I think that's the next stage for labor
so I was more hopeful after yesterday
actually that labor really does
understand the scale of the challenge
and they can never again Jonathan made
this point no matter how bad the
government is you can never rely on that
you've got to focus on your own agenda
your own strategy and Get It Over The
Line what do you make a cursed armor
well I mean actually I think he's doing
a good job now I mean I am so sick of
the Tory government that we just need to
to get labor and power and I have you
know there are things that care does
that I guess that can always on people
of my generation but I just keep saying
like I know so well from growing up with
him and this has been his rhetoric my
entire life there is nothing you can do
when you're not in power so what was it
like growing up with Alistair Campbell
is your dad
which territory for comedy
um it was very interesting never a dull
moment with him I would say
um but it was quite it was also at times
quite stressful I'm very protective of
him you know like I I don't like people
saying bad things about him I I feel
sometimes I have to be with him in case
he gets into an argument so you're a bit
like his bodyguard yeah yeah there have
been moments in my life where if I
wasn't there it would have been really
bad but thankfully I was there and the
thing and he doesn't like fighting in
front of me because he's such a nice guy
you just do it away from grace that
instead right do it useless he used to
take me places when I was a kid so
because then he he felt it would calm
him down if I was there he'd be less
likely to get into a blow up
what's the biggest thing you two
disagree about
um actually you know what I feel he has
I really feel he's listening so much on
like you know women's stuff and I think
you know I do credit myself to a lot of
him now being really aware of things
that he just wasn't anything in
particular that you give an example well
I just like the the treatment of women
and like the things that women go
through that I guess like a lot of men
need to listen to more I need to not
just like pretend they're listening
actually engage in and understand like
what it is like to be a woman in this
Society I use specific example I
actually write about in the book is the
period poverty campaign I'd never really
thought about that
and it was only when Grace came along
with her friend Scarlett Curtis and sort
of sat me down and said that this is
really really bad and why is nobody
talking about this and the next thing
they're running a campaign and they've
got a change in the law but also even on
a sort of like taboo thing he didn't
even like really like talking about
periods then and then I've confronted a
lot of that of like normalizing some of
the conversations that should just not
be a shameful thing for women feel like
that we are last five ten years stuff
like periods we can talk about on TV
which I just can't really imagine that
happening so much when I was growing up
or young women well I can remember the
argument going on in in which budget it
was but there's a budget about whether
there was a discussion about whether we
can say tampon tax
it's ridiculous you actually can't
um now I have to admit right I did an
event recently with your dad and I was
quite surprised by the amount of
attention that he got he was mobbed
there was one woman who came up to you
with a sex Squad badge I mean how on
Earth then he wore it for a week
how would you keep his ego in check yeah
um quite easily yeah I I yeah I mean I
guess you get quite a lot of attention
the other way as well right I think me
and my mum humble him quite a lot
actually humiliated
but I think it's a good thing because he
can get a bit you know big for his boots
sometimes so I think you need to you
were shocked though weren't you I was
but then I have got I'll be honest on
social media there's plenty of people
otherwise oh yeah but they're the ones
who go on social media but the ones who
come to your face tend to be very very
nice that's why it's quite nice to be
learned about yeah just don't go on
Twitter I don't really bother about
Twitter and I tweet too much and I but I
don't look at the comments when we did a
video when I was on tour in Leicester
and we went up to people in the street
saying have you ever heard of Grace
Campbell nobody knew who I was nobody
knew who you were there you go for two
people
earlier on the program and I asked him
about the benefits of brexit to put to
you right he talked about the not having
to be part of the 199 billion pound
covered Recovery Fund he talked about
the free child due with Australia he
talked about the Global Leadership we
showed in Ukraine and he said or above
all it's about democracy so that we
don't have to be told what to do by
Alice Campbell and his mates yeah well
I'd say on the on on Ukraine uh I I
would definitely say that the UK has
done a good job in relation to Ukraine
but that has nothing to do with us being
outside the European Union the
Australian trade deal and all the other
trade deals done they've done they're
either cut and pays for what we had with
the EU or they're adding a minuscule
amount in the long term to our trade
which is none which is meanwhile been
absolutely battered Jacob Reese Mark's
dad is a big part of the book because he
wrote Jacob reesman's dad William wrote
a book back in 1997 called the sovereign
individual and that is what brexit is
about for the Jacob Reese mug types it's
and it's sort in your interview it's
about getting rid of Taxation getting
rid of Regulation and actually getting
rid of democratic control so I actually
think if that's the best he can do for
the benefits given he had the jobs
Secretary of State for brexit
opportunities it underlines to me the
fact that brexit is going very very
badly wrong what about not being told
what to say about us Campbell and his
mates
well I don't think I'd tell anybody what
to do he's he's an elected politician
the government has the power and the
argument I got into your news night the
other night was about this whole
question of sovereignty the whole thing
about sovereignty was a myth because the
sovereignty always lay in the UK
Parliament to pull some of that
sovereignty with other nations and since
we've stopped that I mean I you you
that's cheered me up that because he
Jacob Reese Morgan spends his whole life
thinking about this to me has got not a
single benefit of brexit that he's put
forward well I'm sure that viewers will
draw whatever conclusions they like from
Jacob Reed Smog and as a Campbell thank
you both but what can I do thank you
very much indeed for being on the
program today and really good to have
you on as well